hi my name is Reggie Watts and I feel
quixotic about being Conan O'Brien's
friend very nice I love that no one's
used that word yet I don't think it's
been used on the podcast on the earth in
at least 20 years on the earth yeah true
a quick Sonic
attempt of course after the great Don
kote of course meaning a fanciful vain
attempt at something is quick sotic
sona's quixotic attempt to say something
clever during the interview that kind of
you know what I mean wow okay right you
like that I guess is it I don't know if
that's the proper is it the proper usage
probably not at all but you say it
confidently and it is yeah exactly you
say anything post truth post truth guys
post
Truth uh Reggie you and I got some
history and that's why I'm so thrilled
that you're here today Real History yes
uh you have written a book and you have
a fantastic story to tell and you're uh
very talented and also a very strange
fellow let's just be honest I mean the
glasses alone hold up those glasses so
our viers can see and our listeners um
those are uh are they hexagons what are
those they're hexy they're hexy babies
the future's hexy how many uh now I'm
gonna I'm gonna take because I don't I
don't know if Matt gorley Sona knows
this but I don't know if Matt knows that
uh Sona was on the tour yes we did this
uh T cookie tour uh which was really fun
and out there in
20110 and uh it was a real happening and
we needed someone to open for me on this
tour they went all around the United
States of America and uh we of course we
found Mr Reggie Watts and Reggie was a
great opener for the show and you did an
amazing job and one of the things you
did so brilliantly is people were coming
to the show we put it together so
quickly that nobody knew what it was and
I wanted them to know right away this
isn't the show you thought you were
going to get in fact this is unlike any
show you've ever seen so you can't just
have a standard I just can't have a
comedian come out and go hey everybody
how's it going how you doing hey what's
with the sweater who died and gave you
the sweater because they were dead and
didn't e the sweater anymore that guy
sucks oh that guy's terrible he sucks
he's dead so he doesn't need the sweater
but the sweater is what killed
them um anyway I love that comment that
it's a great bit he is good in context
he's very good in context and you should
really see the sweater he would go after
every night and it was the same sweater
um plant it was a plant hack hack anyway
we couldn't get that guy I wanted that
guy so badly his name's hack B hackstein
we couldn't get him uh no but but uh
someone had heard of have you seen
Reggie Watts and uh you were uh not a
known quantity at the time but we saw
you and you were absolutely exactly what
I wanted and uh you would I mean I can't
even describe what you would do but it
was so original and so fun and so
interesting and so different that people
would come in and they'd see the warmup
and they would think you were there Sona
like oh my God what is happening what is
this going to be uh and it was great you
were perfect it was awesome yeah but you
but you did one thing that completely
blew me away and then I'm going to let
you speak at some point but I'm just
going to monologue for a while because
it's Reggie Watts and I'm very excited
you would no M we were touring in the
summer it was very hot this gentleman
would wear very very heavy sweaters yes
all the time
lots of corduroy and suspenders and
layers and
layers we would be in Texas we would be
in you tell me Georgia it would be 130
Dees and you would be walking around you
never
sweat and then I would be sitting in my
dressing room alone doing guitar scales
and uh trying to warm up my vocals for
the show and just trying to get get
ready and then I would wander down the
hallway and I would pass Reggie's
dressing room and you will testify that
this is true Sona I would pass Reggie's
dressing room and it was always a
happening yes I'm I would look in the
room and there was always about 35
people there beautiful women but with
like an eye Pat a beautiful woman with
an eye patch and a falcon on her
shoulder yeah uh you know yeah exactly
Tanya I mean it really did the coolest
people I've ever and it was it was they
were always different every time it was
different people oh there's a a German
man with a Miner's helmet and he's got a
goat with him but he's also drinking
absin and it was just this insane
collection of human beings and they
would always look at me like V
losin and you'd be like oh hey Conan I'd
be like oh hey and you would all be like
a hookah there doves in the room
Prince was there I don't know like you
had the you it was always a happening
you're the coolest guy I've met how did
you do that how did you and and we'd be
nowhere we'd be like oh we're here in
Tallahassee and there are those people
again and they don't how did they did
you fly them in uh I I don't know how
that you know what really it had to do
with the tour I mean who wouldn't want
to come and hang out backstage at your
tour people were like what is happening
like they like as much as you're saying
like what is happening with this guy
like my friends were like what what's
going on with Conan it's like I'm
opening for that's impo it's impossible
oh let me come you know and I'd be like
yeah it was easy you know everyone was
so excited it was so weird cuz we also
never knew who was going to be backstage
and whatever uh whatever state or city
we were in the most famous people from
that state or city would show up right
and so you know we'd be in Seattle and
they'd say oh uh you know Eddie veter is
GNA Pearl Jam's going to come do
something on the show and I'd be like
what and I'd say this isn't funny this
is hurtful this prank and then Eddie
veter which yeah go ahead my one of my
favorite and this is Aron Blair speaking
now yes I and um I discourage I
discourage his interruptions but go
ahead Aaron I remember I and just so you
know you'll never be allowed to speak oh
no no no I I know that I I saw it in the
contract that t was that t was so nuts I
have a specific memory of being in San
Francisco and I was uh backstage like
trying to get from one side of the stage
to the other and there's this very
narrow hallway and I'm kind of walking
very fast down the hallway and you're
talking to somebody and I just go to
kind of push this person away and as I'm
about to touch I realized you're talking
to Neil Young And I was like oh yeah
maybe I'll just wait don't you
manhandle Neil Young I just waited but
you were such a good you I don't know it
was one of those so many things went
miraculously right on that tour and I
would say the first thing was oh our
opener which was a total Hail Mary we
was Reggie Watts and you just set the
tone right away and whatever happened on
that crazy tour you were like uh-huh of
course this is happening and then of
course as I got to know you better
throughout the tour which was a real
delight and I've seen your career uh
Blossom so beautifully subsequently and
now you have this book out I realized
that you have this
improbable background that kind of made
the you coming into that tour feel like
yeah what else you got you know what I
mean I don't think I don't think weird
situation could be created for you that
you couldn't
handle